I don't get scared I get startled
big difference between those two words
you ask anybody who's ever been a fight
turn around look for their friends
scared they're gone they ran startled if
I'm with you I'll just pick what the
[__] happened oh [__] okay okay
just need to get my bearings about me
and I'm up for cuts and elbows all the
way down
startled not scared
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night past
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media thank you guys for the
support on the special please if you
haven't watched it go watch it it's free
it's up on my YouTube I put it's a labor
of love I directed it I produced it I
worked on the post with it my great
friend Sam vollen we had a great team of
people we scrounged together and
everybody killed it so go watch it it's
called Lefty son it's free it's right
there on the YouTube and while you're
there subscribe to the YouTube it's a
free way to help the channel to show all
that stuff doesn't cost you a dime means
nothing to you and everything to us and
if you gotta have more then you gotta
subscribe to the Honeydew with y'all
it's my patreon show it's only five
bucks there's no tears no levels and
it's the same thing I highlight the low
lights with y'all and as I've said y'all
got the wildest [__] stories I've
ever heard again we've talked to people
who've died we've talked to a girl who
had two [__] we talked to a woman who
had three [__] we talked to a double
lung transplant who married his donor's
girlfriend and they're having a kid we
talked to all kinds of people it's five
bucks a month you subscribe for a year
you get over a month free and you get
the Honeydew a day early you get it ad
free at no additional cost all right now
I'm slowly getting back out there but
it's the time of month here may Fort
Wayne Indiana starting to tour off Ryan
sickler live and Alive May 26th and 27th
in Fort Wayne June 23rd and 24th in
Tacoma Washington July 7th and 8th in
Appleton Wisconsin July 21st and 22nd
Tulsa Oklahoma all right there it is
that's the biz now you're not you guys
know we're doing over here we're
highlighting the low lights these are
the stories behind the storytellers
today very exciting to have this guest
on here first time on the Honeydew
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome Sean
Patton welcome to the Honeydew Sean pack
I did it coming in coming in strong wait
I gotta say you said that was I'm you
said you've talked to people who died
yeah which I I now several of them put
together means died and they came back
right like heart stopped or at a moment
he's doing [__] seances
that's my seven dollars here
if you got a relative you want to try
and get in touch with
I think we can get them I think we just
do Ouija board [__] here I mean dude
there's there's gotta be a seance
podcast right there's no way that
doesn't exist
except it doesn't you better jump on
that [__] call in and just the Ouija
podcast we'll just call in I mean dude
if you ever do it you ever use it wait
Ouija board yes yeah okay we're gonna
talk about that one second but before we
get too far away I want please plug and
promote everything up top we're coming
right back to Ouija board okay so uh
currently I'm on the road with David
Cross for a long time into the summer
and then again in the fall
um you know David Cross uh just just
Google David Crosstour go watch this
episode here and check out his website
but I'm also when I'm not with him I'm
also touring on my own go to my website
me seanpatton.com date your constantly
posted I'm I'm all over the place uh and
then my special on peacock
I had to do that little I had a peacock
for a moment I have a special oh
actually okay so la I did an album for
helium records that I filmed and cut
together that is that is technically a
special it's on YouTube it's called Uh
King Scorpio you can also get the album
version of that that's up on YouTube now
if you want to see me for free but go to
Peacock that's a special I dropped in
December of last year that I love that
is I love the other one but this one's
like a high you know there was some
money behind it Michael Che produced it
Eric Abrams directed it oh man yeah air
caves is the the shout out to Eric shout
out great [__] director for specials
uh we shot it at Tipitina's in New
Orleans my hometown uh you know it was
it's a great special it's on peacock
right now watch it I love it and go
subscribe to Sean's YouTube channel yeah
building building I'm building yeah but
it's good to be here with you to do yeah
thank you man I haven't seen you since
uh we bumped into each other that was my
second weekend of the tour too in
Indiana Indianapolis yeah dude I got a
great time I got I got like what what
happened
also that was the last time I smoked
weed
yeah is that what happened that we did
it that was the last time we were in
that little Alleyway out there yeah I
don't I don't know yeah I don't know if
we should I mean I don't know if we
should say who were you with yeah who uh
who was no one negative no it wasn't
negative I just don't like that there we
go it was my friend Libby yells from
high school and raylen Nelson Rayland
Nelson was there daughter of
granddaughter she lives off a smoker
granddaughter of Willie Nelson yeah it's
a moment where you're just like we
should say yeah we should actually this
is actually what she wants yeah yeah she
but she was the one who was like him
yell and my friend uh Austin their
husband yeah that little crew right man
that weed was coming around well that
was the thing too she raelyn's already
super [__] cool and I'm like yeah I
would love to smoke weed with just you
if you were just if your name was raelyn
Jefferson or did someone but then you're
like oh but you're also Willie Nelson
yeah blood yeah I have to smoke weed
this is the closest anybody in the
Patton family will get to the actual
Willie Nelson himself but she's also
super [__] cool yeah and I did her
podcast is fun as well I can't remember
what it's called did it yeah yeah but
that's how fun it is you just I always
forget the good ones yeah they have a
great podcast I feel like that's life
though you forget the good times and
focus on the [__] ones too much well
watch this transition you know what I'm
not gonna forget Ouija boards
all right so take me back like we were
like almost like the conversation was
over here
naturally guided itself back over there
yeah yeah
man [__]
yeah weird experience with it oh no no
no but I'm like you know
you did I had two that were [__]
mind-blowing were they actually Guided
by one Spirit though one was Guided by
maybe a spirit and stupidity which will
make sense in the end the other one is
wildly questionable so the first one
which is more of the funnier one was um
back I was in ninth grade and my
friend's sister was in 10th Grade their
parents go away to Greece for like a
week so it's party [__] Central and
we're hanging actually they were in 11th
grade so we're little ninth graders
hanging out with these Juniors at this
house party and they decide they want to
do a Ouija board so all the lights are
out those [__] weeds being smoked I'm
you know and then I don't even smoke and
it's just got this Vibe and they're
doing it on a homemade one well that's
not even the Parker Brothers one what
the homemade one which apparently is
worse
so they start doing this [__] scarier
this is in the 80s late 80s okay this
board is made of dried flesh it was a it
was a wood board they made and [__] so
they start doing it and they start
coming up with this whole guy named
Edgar who was from the area and who had
murdered these people whatever so we're
calling [__] on it [__] on a
[__] this is how old it is we drive
it's a mile away to the [__] Library
and then we go research this area and
[__] Edgar was real yeah he was
real [__] it got scary so the whole
weekend we're like what the [__] and
we're doing all this stuff we're going
to the library and it's matching up it's
matching up so finally the like third
night of this uh a friend of mine puts a
pizza in the oven and we'll kill the
lights and we're all sitting down and
um they say Edgar
show yourself this is after like 15
minutes and I swear to [__] God the
goddamn oven door pops open fire shoots
out of the [__] thing we're like oh
my God what and we go over and here's
where the stupidity part comes in okay
this [__] took left the
cardboard
you know under the pizza oh yeah yeah
okay and it caught on [__] fire and
it shot [__] out like that but right
when we said show us a sign I was like I
can't count that because you left the
cardboard on there that's what caught on
fire that wasn't just fire [__] shoes
I tell you what just it's scared the
[__] out of us though but then my
friend's dad comes home and sees us
playing with it and he goes off about
how that's where and he breaks it over
his [__] knee throws it in the trash
and they get it out of there
so then a few a couple years later I do
another one with these two girls uh my
neighbor and she had a girlfriend over
and they're like hey we're gonna do
Ouija board you want to do it and I was
like yeah can we use your basement I was
like sure because our basement was like
an unfinished basement concrete floor
and [__] in Baltimore yeah so we had uh
we turned the cord lights off they light
a candle and we start doing the [__]
thing we're not doing it for more than
two minutes and the [__] candle goes
out I've got the matches I'm go I've got
the cover in this hand and the match in
this hand I'm gonna go strike like this
and I'm telling you Sean Patton yeah
without being anywhere near this
[__] Match Pack this [__]
match lit what burn the [__] out of my
fingers I [__] threw that off I
pulled both those lights on I was like
y'all gotta get the [__] out of here you
and your you and your [__] Ouija
board those are the two experiences I've
had and I've never [__] with them ever
again okay you okay
because I had the exact it's ish it's
ish I mean but it's ish that's still
bullish it's another thing to say never
mind yeah you know what I've forgot
about that See Fire mine were completely
different in a the there is never a
greater time than a moment when you're
doing the Ouija board and you're like
show us a sign to rip a perfectly timed
fart
that was my experience my first
experience for the Ouija board was just
say you know you got the thing and
they're like what is your name and it's
like g u
G it must be Greg because because
everyone's you I remember being like I
feel us all yeah everybody's pushing but
then like are you here now and then why
that must mean yes yeah let's just stop
right there and then can you give us a
sign and then nothing then
that was a sign
I didn't who did that yeah clearly it
was me but
the one time it was kind of this isn't
[__] up I'm not gonna say names but it
turned sexual
but not uh not like it was a bunch of
dudes me and like my buddy and my cousin
like probably [__] were kids and we
basically just started spelling out
[__] and dick and BJ and you know it's
being and then it got like really like
now we're just do you liked when you
were alive we're talking to a spirit
that was a [__] like when you when you
were alive
would you have [__] all three of us
like yes and then my cousin at one point
was just like hey I gotta go to the
bathroom and we're like okay and we
stopped and then he came back and we're
like did you just jerk off
and he was like no and we're like let's
ask the spirit like did he just and we
felt him like no like pushing away I'm
like no it's going towards us why man
I didn't say so am I yours are like
bordering on there was there was a
presence
yeah but I mean I grew up like growing
up in New Orleans there's always like
it's a haunted City everything haunted
let's talk about where you grew up and
how you grew up because you are a New
Orleans kid yes Joe my my my family has
a catering business uh shout out
Patton's catering uh check them out
they're still they're still uh in New
Orleans still in New Orleans um they
catered Norman's wedding back every
night last year I officiated Norman's
world did you really yeah completely
[__] it up did you yeah I mean those
things are weird because you'd like you
know it's fun it was fun as hell but I
messed up the bridal the bridal party
members who were gonna read I like
[__] up their names completely and you
know but Norman and his wife may they
didn't give a [__] it was a fun wedding
but
they own my pet my family owns a venue
in Slidell Louisiana which is like half
an hour north of the city and uh it's
old you perform there you do that no no
it's mainly like it's there it's like
for wedding receptions and events yeah
but it's an old ass house it's
I want to say too it's it's on the
National Registry like it can't be
augmented in any way no [__] it's
historic it's historic right wow and uh
but it's old and afterwards
it's originally called if any history
[__] people out there who know
Louisiana it's called the Salman
fritchie house that was the family that
owned it but now it's just patents but
after Katrina me like my immediate
family and like my uncle and my aunt
like basically four families we lived in
that [__] oh wow because it didn't it
got you know it's about six feet off the
ground it got water but it didn't get
into the house all of my parents house
everywhere else my apartment New Orleans
at the time all of it got ruined so we
lived in this house for like I'm gonna
say two months after the storm and it
was you know it was a sitcom basically
but every single member of my family all
of it claims there they saw the ghost of
that house
at the same time like we all are all
different times and did you see it no
but they all no everybody else but
everybody gave the exact same
description that it was a it was a
little girl and she was in The Wine
Cellar and you would see her only if you
entered the wine cellar from outside did
you try it yeah and The Wine Cellar was
destroyed by because it was it was it's
not they don't really have sellers in
Louisiana yeah it was just under the
house and aren't uh no one's buried
Below in the in New Orleans Parish in
like upside down below sea level yeah
like down in like New Orleans itself
yeah people are above ground right but
like dude it was there but here's the
thing I I'm talking a big game right now
like I'm like they didn't see no [__]
ghost but every time I went to like see
like is there the ghost I would have
[__] vomited and [__] at the same
time fainted I'm having diarrhea because
I'm thinking about walking in there
looking at [__] like oh God but I I we
used to do it all the time we still love
to be scare we used to go down to
Baltimore City cemeteries at two o'clock
in the morning yeah [__] Saturday
night when the fog's rolling in and look
for this [__] one it was a statue of
this black angel and you would sit in
the the feet that looked like that it
was like there was a black angel doing
the Karate Kid yeah
and you would hold on to its leg and
you'd say Black Aggie wait really
[Laughter]
no but the statue's there and you would
sit at the base of it and if you said I
think it was Black Aggie three times in
a row like there was rumors you die at
the foot of it and all that oh yeah and
we would sneak into this Cemetery but
then you would see it in the moon like
you're like Jesus Christ it's huge it's
just my ass looks like a supposed to be
an angel but it looks like a gargoyle
and it's huge like what the [__] you get
those old cities you know Philly and
stuff since 1700s and [__] they had some
wild [__] [__] I mean there's a I
mean like I don't I always I'm
interested in the idea of ghosts but my
my my my issue is I I believe that if
they were as real as people thought it
was there would be true documented
footage oh no doubt yes there it would
happen it would be there bigfoots ghosts
by now with drones and [__] yeah yeah
there would be [__] footage but dude
it's still like you know um like you
know Canadian like his sister they go
and like spend the night like abandon
asylums that you can pay money to go
because they're both just like scare
freaks they just love haunted houses
he's got a whole podcast about it the
boogie monster it's all about scary [__]
I'm like I don't believe any of that
[__] is real but what I'm terrified of
is my own [__] yeah my own mind
running with it and just like because
that's my whole life dude I was afraid
of the dark till I was like 15. were you
really I'm saying that out loud on the
Honeydew podcast to all the dusters out
there
to all the Deuces the Deuce Double
Deuces what were you scared of my own
[__] imagination dude what was you
thinking but is it is it were they
irrational not that your thoughts
wouldn't be rational but irrational
meaning are they monsters and [__] or
are they like like someone's gonna break
in type realistic fear it can be
anything dude like I mean like I having
an imagination like what an imagination
is one of the greatest things any human
being can have right but there's also a
negative side to it like anything
there's a dark side to it and that's
great but I also have obsessive
repulsive disorder it's dark side to
that as well it's mostly a dark side but
there's a light side to that as well I
talk about my OCD in my peacock special
extensively by the way saying that right
to the viewer but um but it's like I
can't watch horror films without
obsessing about them for weeks
afterwards so it's it's a chore for me
to watch a horror film so what's the uh
okay what's the first horror film you
watched yeah that's a that's a hard one
that's a that's still a hard one that's
a hard one my daughter was just had the
stomach flu and was throwing up like
that's all I think about every time you
see that projectile bomb and she turned
to look them I go hey keep your head
over the toilet she just goes wow all
over my feet I'm like God damn it yeah
and that is such a scary proposition in
itself the idea of like demonic
possession because if you grow up in the
South or in probably in on the East
Coast too yeah we got Edgar Allan Poe
right right with sharks
tell that heart where it is
Telltale Heart The Raven all the Raven
the he banged his cousin you know like
that's a that where's that novel where's
that where's that where's that yeah
right where's that at Edgar Allan of the
poem of how sweet that cousin [__] is
but um
that was too much there's your clip me
looking into Cameron saying that but you
grow up Catholic by default
you know what I mean 100 yeah we did
sure all of the better schools in in the
New Orleans metropolitan area anyway are
Catholic and the problem with going to
Catholic schools is you get it ingrained
with Catholic theology and you start to
you know as a kid you pray in school and
you start to think this way so the idea
of a demonic possession as a kid was
terrifying to me and watching The
Exorcist just
you know what I'm saying yeah we're in
Baltimore that shit's in Georgetown
that's like you know a 45 45 minutes
yeah trip down the street it's right
there but then like you know seeing like
uh early Friday the 13th yeah that [__]
was early early that [__] was like
original Halloween was really [__]
scary it still holds up yeah the
original Nightmare on Elm Street yeah
those were all [__] like I can fall
asleep so it's scarier to go to sleep
than this beer in the dark so like I'm
talking till I was like 15 years old I
slept with a nightlight or a light on
oh what's this dumb [__] oh [__] I guess
I gotta my mom's making me do that that
was my excuse me my mom dude whenever
whenever friends would be over like is
that a [__] NightLight I'd be like
nah dude my mom makes me leave it on in
case I gotta go to the bathroom or
something it sucks I'm gonna plug it now
my mom sucks you're in here you know
also I was a bad weather so I'm like and
a dog pissed my bed where are you to
hell I was a bad weather probably till
around the same age really yeah both of
my brothers were too they were
bedwetters well how'd you stop uh
becoming uh puberty just stop it I mean
it it took it was a process but like
realizing like oh this is not this will
ruin any chance I have at friendship
everything sleepovers I remember like my
brother's probably like [__] you but
um like everybody would if we went to my
aunt's place or whatever they would put
like a plastic sheet down or whatever
but you know what stopped them so again
I'm 50. I have a twin who's also 50
obviously and then my younger brother
twin yeah we're fraternal though we look
nothing like okay we got these two
different people no because I was gonna
be like is it am I talking to Ryan right
now yeah or is this Jeffrey
um my younger brother's almost about
four years younger and those two would
would wet the bed and they had this
thing where
um you had to wear a T-shirt and like
tighty whities and it was a buzzer that
you sewed on your T-shirt right here and
it had a little battery and it had a
cord that ran down to this patch in your
oh the night tone is that what it's
called and it buzzes yeah I had that
okay so that's what they had and it
[__] worked it for both of them
here's the thing dude I had I talked
about this in the special as well for
real it's for all what it's called a
nighttime
let me tell you something you know who
never got sleep I had to share room with
this [__] he had a retainer he
would go all night and then he'd be
pissing me and I'm like God damn I never
slept but that was never slow but okay
my problem with the thing was the design
because the idea was it's a big chunky
thing yeah I went on my wrist mine you
wore like a wrist right how old are you
this I wore that from when I was like 11
to how old are you right now oh 40 44.
so we got okay six years yeah we must
have got to early uh earlier mine went
on the wrist so like uh but my thing was
the whole idea was it would you know
wake you up and then you'd stop pissing
but I'm like when is being started came
out though or when it's being startled
ever stop someone from pissing
he jumped
he jumped but I would wake up and just
and just disconnect it like a snooze
button uh it's disconnected didn't get
up and actually go wake up and just be
oh dude it was bad I mean my first ever
sleepover I remember vividly uh Kenny a
bear shout out if you're still alive I
don't know what's up candy yeah but his
birthday party there was like a group of
us from school I was of I was like the
kid who was invited because his mom and
my mom worked together none of those
dudes like me but I was in school with
them we were all like sixth graders I
think you're the outcast of that group
for that group and like everything
[__] but my mom we had this whole
speech this whole conversation about how
I wasn't gonna pee the bed not to drink
any soda past a certain hour et cetera
et cetera and like we were hanging out
and then we all went out there's maybe
six of us we went out into the streets
to roll houses what's that toilet paper
okay yeah I was a little [__] [__]
and I was like guys we shouldn't be
doing this and I was like scared I was
scared to do it they're like this
[__] kid sucks well go home then
[__] go back home so I went I went back
to Kenny's house we also snuck out yeah
right so I snuck back in to the bedroom
through the window and his mom was just
sitting in there and she turns the
lights on she's like where are they
you're the only one that came in so then
she goes into the snitch exactly oh so
now I'm the snitch they all [__] hate
me and but it but as a reward as a
reward for being uh for telling her the
mom she lets me sleep on the sofa bed
and watch a movie while they all have to
sleep in Kenny's room no movies we were
all gonna sleep in the living room and
watch a movie but all right you're even
more like this [__] Friday the
13th because I don't know because I was
like we were supposed to be watching a
movie in Kenny's room we were what there
was a movie playing man but we had snuck
out that's where it was but then they
were like no more movie sean gets to
watch the movie on the sofa bed and I'll
be okay and I remember the movie it was
the first home alone right
um you're out there just laughing out
loud
life is how can this get any worse oh
the next morning when I wake up having
hosed the water bed or the sofa bed just
full Sprout like I'm talking
Lake Shawn you know what I mean just
like a full-on
so now not only do they all [__] hate
me but the parents hate me so I'm just
like the most hated 12 year old
come on no dude his dad drugged the
mattress out back and hold and I
remember I remember him just hosing it
all down he's not getting the new yeah
Jose like wetting the entire thing and
then getting laundry detergent and
pouring in there and like trying to like
wash it in the backyard on like that it
was [__] insane and I was like should
I help I don't know
then she had to call my mom to come get
me early it was a bad it was a it was
one of those like that's terrible yeah I
don't think I had a friend again until I
was like a freshman in high school but
that's like that's motivation to stop
being the best it starts there
oh man that's bad oh yeah dude it's that
my my
Teenage life was [__] hard without me
whenever you see these teenagers now who
are like crushing it on YouTube making
millions yeah [__] man so what were you
like did you play sports did you date
did you I was way too what are you doing
and getting into then I was a very shy
kid
spent a lot of time alone right A lot of
times you have siblings I do but I'm I'm
way older than well not way over like my
I have a sister who's four years younger
another sister who's 10 years younger my
brother's 14 years damn okay so there
was like gaps right so um I was a
[__] just alone and uh we
I spent a lot of time in my head which
I'm which I like now I just spent a lot
of time like imagining things I was just
walking around the neighborhood by
myself just like
imagining a different life imagine what
if I was this what I had a very active
imagination as a kid so it kept me
that's why I like I say this all the
time it's fact I've never been alone
I've never felt loneliness or boredom a
day in my life it's [__] weird like
when people talk about being bored I'm
like really you don't have 15 scenarios
to just restructure in your head you
don't have this one alternate reality
you occasionally visit from time to time
where you're like what if I was what if
I did this for a living what if I were
an FBI agent what if I was an ABC also
what a magical City to be in with that
imagination too you're not in just some
[__] middle of nowhere I was in the
[__] suburbs growing up like my parents
are both from the lower knife like
they're a legit hardcore New Orleans but
they moved us out to we were in New
Orleans East which is like the Jersey
of New Orleans yeah yeah yeah and then
we and then Xiao met which is like the
Staten Island
and then and then slide down eventually
which is like the Yonkers you know I'm
using New York because it's just the
easiest one to get but like
um yeah I was just a [__] dweeb but
my friends the only friends I really had
growing like in my like from like 13 to
maybe 16 were cousins because I had a
lot of cousins my age right so it's
almost cousins are great because they
kind of have to hang out with you you
know I mean there's like okay we've got
to but I was you know I get along with
my cousin still but I had something like
I have a cousin I know I've I would love
to know what he's up to but I probably
will never speak to him again because he
this life went veered in different right
directions and I kind so
when I was I was 13 right Chalmette
Louisiana if you've ever been I mean I
think Staten Island's a it's a joking
description but xiaomat's just like an
industrial [__]
sort of uh it's I'm not saying the
people are [__] I'm just saying the
actual area it's not it's a it's just
east of New Orleans it's about 10 miles
east of New Orleans it's where the
Chalmette National Battlefield is we're
an actual like Revolutionary War battle
took place and it's like that's
beautiful but the rest of it's just flat
dirty low rent they're called
chalmations or yats it's like you get
[__] made fun of a lot as a
chalmation and every other part of New
Orleans but
good there's good people there but
there's a wood there's a lot of wooded
areas up there right so me and my cousin
and one of my other friends we used to
always ride our bikes and go into the
woods we're just like this I think
everybody's experienced this in a suburb
you grow up in the woods it's the first
place you want to go as a teenage boy
yeah just freedom in the woods at first
it starts with just like yeah you know
playing as innocent games I'm gonna be
this character you guys then it becomes
like I have some flag and stuff we did
Manhunt a lot yeah what's Manhunt it's
where one one person gets like a 10
minute Head Start after that everybody's
just getting everybody else is trying to
capture the one man yeah yeah and you
know basically just like grown up hide
and seek but there was no hiding you
were just trying to it's or elude but um
and then it turned into like first place
I ever smoked a cigarette you know first
place I ever smoked weed first place
ever [__] saw a girl's tits first
time ever I think I mean I'm saying this
honestly first time ever remember
jerking off like a man
like hand pulling on the putt when you
say hold on jerking off like a man you
mean yourself well I think not another
man yes jerking off myself
yeah but my early masturbation I would
lay flat in the woods no in the woods
yeah the first time I remember like what
is the classic masturbation technique of
lubricant
joinking it was in the woods at night
within with like a nudie mag no [__] in
the woods in the woods in the middle of
[__] nowhere no one no one around but
like just like yeah I knew where the new
I knew where the log was where you
rolled it back and it was just a bunch
of [__] playboys and penthouses
you know and they just people just add
to it that's I mean that's today's kids
are never even gonna know it they're
never gonna even understand fisting.com
right now yeah yeah Community jerker
pushing a log away to see some titties
and sometimes you'd go back there and
it'd be a fresh mag and you're like
I mean the first time you see a hustler
and you're like holy Jesus Hustler was a
little mind-blowing back then yeah like
now that's mild yeah now it's nothing
now it's like a hello yeah yeah now you
can like show your kid that joke
you know you got that on people wear
like
people got t-shirts of just like spreads
it's like it's a woman's body what do
you do I'm looking inside your [__]
yeah it's my profile pic big deal yeah
my name's Karen but I mean pre that time
when I used masturbation would be laying
flat on the ground and just swiping
right and left on a carpet you know yeah
and then just blowing blowing blowing
whatever into your [__] underwear but
like a little personal there but
that's what podcasting's about yeah my
cousin never tried to attack me my
cousin uh I don't know if I want to use
his real [__] name oh I'll call him
JJ though because he went by initials
like that my cousin and my buddy Bobby
um I could probably use Israel on Amazon
video but um we were in the [__]
woods and we were just [__] around
being I was 13 we're all 13 pretty much
just being [__] kids and we're riding
our bike outs we're wiring our bikes out
of the woods and there's these like four
Dudes and they have fireworks that was a
big [__] thing in Louisiana year
round somebody had bottle rockets and
jumping jacks you can get those any time
of year and bottle rocket wars were fun
you know what I mean oh yeah little Moon
Travelers
splashing at each other right and the so
jumping jacks those were a little more
high-end but you'd unraveling remember
you unravel the packs and just get
little individual ones you like those
so we ride by those guys and just sort
of like they see I remember I remember
being like Oh we can join in maybe these
guys will let us and I asked one of the
guys I'm like hey man are you are the
are any of these for sale and I remember
the dude I remember I still remember the
dude's look which is look I didn't
identify then but I'll look now I I
would know definitively as oh we're
gonna [__] these kids up like it's just
straight up like dude he gave me this
look of just like
and I was like this thing of like oh
sorry and he's like no no what's your
name come here come here and I remember
like walking over they were a little
older and I was like oh yeah just you
know I'm Sean whatever and he lit a
bottle rocket right he said here you go
he lit it he's like throw it right when
he put it in my hand he then held my
hand so it just burned the [__] out of
your hand yeah burn it but it was just
those little Moon traps yeah I know so
it wasn't like a [__] it wasn't like
a big daddy but it was enough to be like
ow ow but I was such a [__] wuss that
I was just pretending like it was like
yeah [__] oh that sucks but you know
just like that's totally cool and then
my cousin JJ got like hey what the [__]
man and then they just beat the ever
living [__] [__] out of them
so two of the guys held me down because
buddy my other guy and I don't I ain't
mad at him for this but he took off my
buddy Bobby just got right on his bike I
got a friend too right just got the [__]
out of there and in my head I was like
oh he's probably gonna come back with
people
he's coming back with parents he's
coming back so I remember that being a
lingering thing in the back of my head
like Bobby's gonna come back at some
point but my cousin JJ he steps up one
of the guy's like what the [__] you said
and my cousin was like a scrappy dude he
didn't give a [__] so he like gets you
know bows back up and they want first
it's just one-on-one and it's fine and
then when the other guys jumps in and I
try to like I'm just like screaming at
the top of my lungs and one of the guys
is holding me [__] still he's like
you [__] move I'll [__] kill you
little [__] [__] and I'm like
and they're just now three on one but
they're not just beating them up they're
now treating him like a
I guess the best way to describe it
would be like if you saw three future
sociopaths torturing a dog you know what
I'm saying they were [__] him I
remember they did the thing where they
they lit a jumping jack packet and put
it down the back of his shirt oh my God
now he quickly like once it went off he
like threw his shirt off and like ran
away from it they thought it was
hilarious they were throwing [__]
logs at him and [__] and there's a canal
this is one of the worst this is a thing
that like
I didn't understand I think
I think there is some you know uh it's
important to identify child trauma now
we understand that [__] you know what I
mean but like this is something I can
honestly say traumatized like my first
experience of like oh that's what trauma
was because I had nightmares about this
moment I had [__] I would have like
days where I would be fine and then out
of nowhere just like the memory of it
would spin me back but can I ask you
when you would have these nightmares was
it true to the memory of what happened
or would you see the worst [__]
happening you're reliving it literally
it was how it happened yeah it was
pretty true to the memory but it was
also like it was just the feeling I had
it was a feeling of like utter
hopelessness as a kid but then basically
there's a canal right there canals are
everywhere in Southern Louisiana but
like Southeast Louisiana there's a cat
Canal right there so they're beating the
[__] [__] on him and he kind of falls
into the bank of the canal right and
he's just so he's on the low ground and
they've got The High Ground And I'm just
there being like I'm not even being
physically respected trained anymore but
they're basically like if you leave I'm
gonna [__] thing she's gonna kill you
and also I'm not gonna run I'm just like
I'm terrible I'm just Frozen in fear
right watching this happen to my cousin
so every time he tries to come back up
they throw something at him or they kick
them back down and then they eventually
I don't
I'm guessing they eventually decide like
let's see if how far we can get to the
point of killing this kid because now
they're like advancing on him and I
remember three of them and I remember
they give them the option of jumping
that [__] Canal we're gonna throw you
in do you have uh Gators and [__] in
those canals no but those canals are
like undercurrents and undertows and
just full of white [__] waste and
[__] like they're just disgusting and
he's not backing down I Will Always
Forever remember like him just being
like [__] y'all like he was not backing
down but they were like just hurling
[__] pieces of wood Adam grabbing
chunks of mud and just throwing [__] at
him and then one guy just is like [__]
this and goes down and starts like you
know throwing punches and they're
fighting again and he knocks them on the
ground just kicking him in the [__]
head kicking him in the back and he
eventually rolls into the canal Jesus
now he's not in the middle of the canal
but he's in the water right and I
remember he just stayed in the water he
was defeated he was just eventually like
I'm done here I'm I there's nothing else
I'm just gonna stay in the water and the
three guys come out one of them grabs
his bike and just ghost rides it at him
right so he has to just sort of like
SWAT his bike aside it rolls deeper into
the canal
it's [__] gone they're done torturing
him eventually they they're done with me
I'm just [__] Frozen I'm just a
little [__] wet rag at this point
they leave he comes back up uh I had
pegs on my bike like on the back so I
rode him home right he had to ride on
the back of your bike after he got his
ass beat like that dude he just let him
lay it on you yeah and then what a
miserable way to have to go home after
that dude and then I saw it it was
brutal and like we get to his house and
his older brother my older cousin was
like a legit badass was like a legit
like he's five years older than me I
think but like you know a scrappy
everybody was afraid of of will he was a
[__] bad dude and I remember him
scolding me because when he came home
he's like what the [__] happened to him
and he was like he went to the bathroom
and I told him the whole story crying
and [__] and then his brother pulled me
outside and he's like what the [__] kind
of [__] little [__] are you you
didn't [__] you do a [__] thing and
he just let me have it I'm just like I
know I know I know and that ruined like
that sect of my family and my immediate
family just
really never really healed from that
really yeah I remember when my so your
your cousin so what's the connection
who's to your mom and dad her uh their
dad is my mom's brother got it and that
even affected your mom and him oh yeah
wow yeah because they called my mom and
they were like Sean what the [__] and I
mean what no one ever blamed me but you
know I was there when JJ got the [__]
kicked out of him right and when my
uncle died which was like late 90s we
were like you know maybe five years
later four years later
um we went to his funeral it was very
like you know I hadn't seen any of them
in years and it was very like you know
it was a funeral it was sad but I could
tell like he was not he I don't think he
ever that had to [__] with him forever
you know because I also think about his
position of he's seeing me his cousin
not doing [__] but I was a little
[__] strong he just wuss dude I was
like terrified of the idea of getting
they would have [__] me up just as bad
but now if I could go back in time I'd
have taken the beaten a hundred percent
without doubt a thousand percent like
that's one of those why just to let this
just so he would feel some camaraderie
just so he would feel like I because I I
think about that was part of the the
thing that I spun it this has affected
my relationship with people
immensely I think it's kind of what
turned me into an empath though because
I think way more about other people than
I think about myself right always but
like I think I've put myself in his
position so many times of just being
like what if that was happening to me
what if I'm getting the [__] [__]
kicked out of me and I have another
person who's not doing anything and then
I feel I cycle through the anger I know
immediately it pisses me off and then
immediate makes me sort of feel sorry
for the person but in a way where you
don't want to help where you just kind
of want to disconnect it [__] with me
it like I think that event just
[__] just [__] the bed in how I made
friends and dealt with people for years
and you were how old at that time 13 13.
13. and he was what just a little older
nice name like I think maybe I maybe
like a month older than him and it
affected you in what way you're just
scared to even like talk to people or
get to know him get close to them I
think I think it was a thing of like I
felt like uh
I I think I felt like if you befriend me
I will let you down
if you if you come around me in any way
if I if I if you trust me I'm gonna
[__] violate that somehow because I'm
a loser I'm a piece of [__] it just you
know set me down that spiral of like I
am nothing right so how long did that
last I mean probably until
I mean I started doing stand-ups more
scared of dark first
dark the dark by that point that's
probably what ultimately let me not give
a [__] about the dark anymore I would
say yeah like [__] it need an afternoon
reset do yourself a favor and snag five
minutes for a dag grass tote break or
two they've got Mom grass joints is the
perfect pick me up to spark your
creative flow or the original digress
joins to quiet your mind after you're
nine to five that grass is legal it's
organic smokable hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind they're 100
organic pre-rolled joints and flour are
very low in THC and high in CBD so you
can enjoy the effects of CBD while
keeping a clear head if you're not
looking to toke that grass also offers
the finest tinctures and gummies on the
market all the Mellow goodness no smoke
required all digress products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the U.S so whether you're looking for a
new Buzz are a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite that grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now that grass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to daggrass.com
honeydew go to daggrass.com honeydew for
20 off your first order that's
dadgrass.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
because I also remember the first like
actual physical fight I ever got into
where I was like oh that was a fight was
when I was about to those 14 turn 15. oh
so after this after that and it was like
a legit real full-on brawl like me and
two guys versus like four guys and I
mean we all everybody it was one of
those classic like every single human
being involved got their ass whipped
nobody won that fight nobody lost that
fight everybody just got hit but the
moment that fight's about to start did
you know no matter what I'm I'm doing
this one no matter what I was part of
the instigation I was part of the
process that was part of the reason
because the girl it was a guy's
girlfriend
was flirting with me I see and her and I
were like talking on the phone and he
found out and came to my house with
dudes to your house yeah but but he we
knew each other kind of but I had
friends as well they were there so we
like decided on like meet at the [__]
meet at chamela it was a country club
with a parking lot right and no one was
there and we like meet there we went and
we just [__] beat the [__] out it was
like but I knew it was like I can't but
also it was like pent up probably pent
up aggression and rage and
disappointment in myself and like all
this [__] I mean I can still remember
like taking punches and thinking like
this wouldn't have been that bad yeah
the adrenaline is official right and
like I think back about like what if
like I just sitting there as a kid would
have picked up a [__] tree branch and
just whacked one of those [__] guys
you know what I mean and then sure they
would have came back at me with some
[__] but they were also older like I'm
guessing these dudes were all 16 15 16.
they were definitely older than us but
like they were and bigger well I don't
know but I can I I would love to know
where they all were I don't even know
their names you know I mean I'll never
know who those guys were and even with
the success you've had and stuff your
cousin hasn't reached out it's it's been
a split thing forever yeah you do shows
his older brother and I still talk you
do yeah he like years later like reached
out about it but no my the younger the
cousin his younger brother Mike I I
haven't spoken to that guy this century
wow in the 21st century I don't have no
clue what he's up to in life
I just think it's like one of those like
do you miss them
I mean he was like my boy when we were
kids you know what I mean like from we
grew up together the same age we went to
we went to different schools but we were
in the same [__] we were going
through the same [__] at the same time
but I remember like comparing boners
with him
I hear this [__] a lot I've never
circled Kirk at least
I never like bare dick but like being
like kids and having morning Woods at
sleepovers would be like what oh in your
shorts and stuff yeah well you can't
help yeah I thought you meant you really
pulled them out and like let me see
yours oh no no okay I did I did have
cousins uh female cousins who there was
the show me yours show me mine moment
where it's just weird and then you're
like well now we can't talk for
six months since we just saw each
other's genitals
yeah like that that's all good yeah that
was a [__] so
this whole incident you say it really
traumatized you and affected you when
when did you start to get over that
feeling like uh was it after this fight
were you like all right this wouldn't
have been that bad I could I know I can
at least take this and weather this yeah
yeah I mean did that help really yeah
like that made I remember that I don't
think I recognized it fully at the time
but yeah I think like that definitely
you know because I was also a piece of
[__] teenager once I got like in my late
teens like I mean I stole my [__]
Mom's van you know I was I was always
all I was I was terrible in school I was
a horrendous student you would you go at
the van where'd you just Joyride uh
drove a friend of mine in New Orleans to
so we could buy a QP of weed you stole
your Mom's van to go buy a quarter pound
a week and not just a cruise yeah yeah
did you get it yeah did your mom find
out why you took it no all right I mean
she knows now because I talked she's a
fan she messages us yeah yeah she knows
now yeah you should let me some of that
no but um and then like you know we
[__] I I mean dude I forged a report
I forged report cards for an entire year
my entire sophomore year high school I
forged four report cards right and I did
it right I never said I got straight A's
I gave myself C's and D's so every time
my parents would be disappointed they'd
take something away they'd be like you
know you can't you grounded this one
weekend or you got to come home every
the next two weeks you got to be here
you know by 5 p.m but they but they were
they thought I was passing when in
reality I was just straight F's I was
skipping class I was sleeping in class
but I forged the report cards well
enough and when my dad when I actually
got busted when I actually got busted
because I was just doing it on like
stock paper and when my dad saw like a
friend of mine's report card which looks
like a Scantron yeah wait a second and
then he called the school and I dude
that was one of those days I don't know
if you ever had that moment hell no he
went and did all that he went through
all that research oh no he just called
the school and was like hey this is one
of my sons showing me his [__] he's
just like yeah he's like he like when
and then he went and showed like he went
to the school while I was in school who
went like it was there he went to school
because they would give you this is
where this is where I don't know how
they do it now they probably email it
but back in my back in the 90s they just
give you your report card for you to
take home ours was on this like weird
paper though almost like carbon copy
paper yeah it was something yeah it
wasn't a regular it smelled it had like
a weird scent like a ditto it was
regular [__] paper it was like all
printed out and yeah so what happened
when you got caught well you ever have
that thing happen where you come home as
a kid
and you you walk in and the way the way
your parents are just sitting there
waiting for you it's like oh [__] like I
know it was like a moment we're like uh
something I have done I just got busted
for and my dad had uh new copies of my
actual report cards because they gave
they reprint them for them and then all
the fake ones and it was just but he
pointed out he's like if you'd have put
this much effort just in the [__]
school
you wouldn't have had a fake you you
know what I mean I was like uh I guess
but I mean I was a [__] Terror I
dropped out of high school you did yeah
senior year why because I missed too
many days to pass so you were already
you would have had to repeat a year Well
that'd be right [__] it and they give
you the option right then and there they
were like you can either repeat the year
next year and you're done this year or
here's your other option drop it out in
Louisiana when you drop out they give
you this big ass very blue piece of
paper that you then have to go to every
one of your classes right then and there
there's like a timeline there's like you
have 30 minutes to complete this task
really yeah and you have to have every
teacher sign it and then you bring it
back and it's official right but you're
doing it's it's done that way on purpose
I think it's the same thing with like
making pregnant women watch ultrasounds
like they make you go I mean on a far
less degree but they make you go to
class and like classes are in session
right people you know are in there like
oh my God what are you doing like you
know and the teacher is going to sign it
and they're all going to be a little bit
they're all going to be kind of dicks
about it like oh finally Mr Patton's
leaving us huh well you slept through
the first three weeks this doesn't
surprise me good luck out there kid good
luck out there working at a car wash or
whatever they all say some dick [__] and
then you go back and then you're
officially no longer a high school
student now that you have a graduate
equivalent or a GED you have that no you
don't you're never even bother with that
I'm about to con I'm about to confess
something
I've been lying about getting a GED my
entire life up until this exact moment
I just lying to who everyone everyone
who's ever if it's ever popped up you
could have said yeah because it was
embarrassing when I was when I was okay
I never I I went to get my GED and then
was just like I sucked at this part the
school part [__] this part so I just
stopped going and lied to my parents
they think you have one they don't think
I have one they my parents they know the
truth for a while they did but for a
while they're just like when do we see
it I'm like oh no they mail it to me and
obviously I'm assuming you never went
and took any college courses or anything
like that I just completely walked away
from it oh [__] but for years when I was
like a 20 year old kid you know or like
even like back then when my friends were
like what are you doing now I'm like oh
I'm getting my GED and then I'm like
yeah I got my GED and just to say it
just to get them off my back and then
like the next thing you know you're 44
and on a podcast and you're like
it doesn't actually matter it doesn't at
all it has zero you know it it almost
like I did everything on my own I you
know just tackled comedy and you know
here we are but like yeah I don't I'm
not saying don't get a cheese education
is important but I but yeah I have I
have lied to it I have yup there we go
I'm confessing right now I've told so
many people throughout the course of my
life that I have a GED never got one
how's that feel that feels [__] good
good get it off your chest I went to
like four classes there it is your whole
senior year no the GED course oh it was
like a it was like a four-week class I
went to maybe four of them total
um all right I want to talk about
another story because I asked people to
come in with um multiple race yeah I
will say well let me I will say this I
will say
all that [__] up Darkness all that
[__] all that crazy things I mean like I
also the early stages of my obsessive
compulsive disorder definitely were
rooted in that moment as well I mean it
was already in me but like
you know like
I developed ticks and a little you did
oh I mean everyone who has OCD has
little rituals little ticks little
compulsions okay I did yeah I would
count by I would run my fingers across
the remote control that I have one two
three and I would just count by threes
oh yeah dude I would run up and down
stairs and count every step I took all
the time took me a long time you stopped
doing that [__] what was it but was it
rooted in consequence
no meaning like if I didn't do this x
number of steps I'm gonna trip or fall
or something but no no it was just
something I couldn't stop oh no because
for me the type of ocean yeah it was all
based in control so for example I had
certain ticks that were to prevent
anyone from ever being beaten like that
again in front of me because it's all
OCD is about control it's all it's
rooted in control it's your you you try
to control the uncontrollable through
these like compulsions and ticks which
you know aren't real you know have zero
bearing on anything the truth is you're
just terrified of what if what if I
don't do this thing I've been doing what
if I don't kiss the [__] Pepsi can
every time I open it before I that was a
thing for a while I used to feel that
way about praying when I was a kid
because of the Catholic church I better
pray for every dead relative or I'm
gonna burn in hell I'll say a person
right I'm gonna burn it out and even
though you know it's not true you're
still terrified of what if right what is
yeah the one day I don't oh it's a
sliding glass door and I don't walk
through it backwards what if that's the
day that was that a thing for you yeah
was it it was a sliding glass door I had
to walk it backwards what was the
mindset so you ever hear the theory of
sliding doors uh I know the movie and
I've but I don't I don't remember before
the movie even exists see I'm not even
familiar all I know is what I knew was
that it had something to do with
alternate realities okay I was gonna say
parallel universe something introduced
to me like I don't you know I mean I
think now most people are introduced to
parallel universes by like the mar the
Marvel [__] yeah I my Dad loved Michael
Crichton and Stephen Hawking okay those
were his [__] still to this day his
boys right I read Jurassic Park as a kid
Jurassic Park was probably the first
novel I remember really yeah no [__] A
lot of it over the head but you got yeah
for a kid who didn't like school that's
impressive yeah yeah and he he didn't
make me but he highly recommended I read
A Brief History of Time by Stephen
Hawking which I slogged through
didn't understand most of it but every
now and again
you'd get something out of it and then I
remember there was a conversation in
that about I believe I believe I could
be wrong could be something else I read
but I just remember the idea of like an
alternate universe but the idea for me
was that my what I had experienced uh in
being in this universe so much [__] had
happened in my life that I wanted all of
it to be behind me so I would enter
backwards it was but but that was do but
that became more like that control that
stopped whatever negative awful thing I
could think of from happening to other
people that would prevent it how are you
doing that at other people's homes or do
not oh buddy I was you [__] just
though that's that's the thing about
most people that's with with STD or on
STDs STDs
bumps I got and why and where from and I
only got those bumps because I had this
one compulsion where I had to put a
condom on
every time I had sex I had to put a
condo on first but um everyone with both
STDs and OCD they are similar you will
never know until you know yeah yeah
that's you know what I mean yeah
but most people with OCD are [__]
ninja like at hiding the text so you
would still be able to slide in a back I
mean step in a sliding glass door
backwards and not even happen because
you would open it and then find a way to
be like wait is the light still on oh it
is
you know that's good dude constantly or
slide it open like wait what they're
talking to me and then you're out the
door it just you know what I mean I mean
I talked about this dude I you're good
at these [__] I talked about
this one on Dr Drew but for I'm talking
years man
I would I had them at midnight wherever
the [__] I was at midnight I had to
microwave exactly nothing I had nothing
at a microwave nothing for exactly 33
seconds
how would you be able to do that every
night now when you're living with your
parents easy go downstairs in the
kitchen do it right and if they ever if
they were ever in there when uh I mean I
did this probably four or five times I
would just pretend like I was
microwaving something couldn't you
actually put something in there well
here's the thing that tick was all based
around preventing the nuclear apocalypse
right let's explain that here we go
Jesus Christ
33 years old when he died okay you burn
up 33 seconds in something that is
nuclear or radioactive why at midnight I
just because it was the start of a new
day a new day yeah very simple and all
of this [__] was insane but I remember
the first time I did it was because you
know and you made that up yourself that
Jesus is 33 if I do this in a nuclear at
midnight or that came to you some
through Reading find that you never
actively make them up your brain sort of
just puts all these I see what ifs in a
scenario and you either choose or don't
choose but most of the time don't choose
because it's a disorder to act upon it
and the first time you do it it
solidifies I love this stuff all right
so here's a question I have for you have
you ever started to do something where
you're even your OCD is like man [__]
that one no no I mean you just get them
and they're on and then eventually you
overcome eventually you find ways to
overcome like I started going to therapy
when I was 18 because I started having
like massive anxiety attacks which are
connected to OCD and then I was I I had
a full day when I was convinced I was
insane and it was after I dropped out of
school that's the other thing after I
dropped out of high school I still
pretended to go to high school for like
two weeks if it's what your parents like
you'd get up and where would you go
anywhere sometimes I would just walk
around Slidell which is stupid because I
got caught sometimes I would go into the
woods when they would leave I'd go back
home but I couldn't always do that
because my dad would just pop in and out
of home a lot uh go to friends houses
when I knew they were because I also had
friends who were seniors who only had
half days ah so I would just hide out
until they were they'd come pick me up
but I was I had to like simultaneously
be like hey I dropped out of high school
two weeks ago B uh I think I'm insane
now and I explained why my mom it was an
RN so she was like that sounds like an
anxiety attack I'm like well it's been
going on for three days like I was
terrified I'm terrified of everything
and we went and saw a therapist and you
know diagnosed OCD and et cetera but
like
uh what was my point about that oh all
the [__] darkness and all that [__]
leading up to it
it sucks and like yes if I could have
gone back in time like I said I would
have taken the beating with my cousin
but I couldn't have taken this I can't
go back in time there it did eventually
I did eventually turn that [__] into
comedy because I do feel like laughter
became my release of just this constant
like
self-judgment negative self-talk what a
piece of [__] what a [__] loser you
are so but then making other people
laugh became like a see you're good for
a second
so I do think like anyone out there
going through anything
I I the life is all about perception if
you find a way to turn it into something
useful I think that's the key to life
truthfully we're all going to experience
Trump traumatic shitty horrible events
that are out of our control it's this
whole show turning the [__] show into
the funny stuff you're over you turn
yeah a traumatic moment in your life
into comedy well into an ability to like
yeah at least want to make people laugh
yeah a desire to be like oh making you
laugh
almost like makes up for me not jumping
in and [__] trying to help myself
that really did stick with you huh yo
buddy I mean I talked I've talked about
I talked about this event like maybe it
was like 10 years ago but with a
therapist and they were like do you not
talk about this on stage and I'm like I
just haven't found a way to yet well I
can tell you I feel like it's super
relatable most people are scared to get
in fights yeah period yeah then you're
getting jumped by older people that's a
pivotal age too eighth ninth grade or
whatever it is 13 I was in the states
seventh grade so these are like these
are these are men to you basically they
can drive and [__] you know what I mean
yes that's terrifying and then to bring
humor to it something I think that a lot
of people would really connect with and
relate to yeah I mean it's but it's also
I mean people have told me stories about
[__] they've gone through and I'm like
man
that there's some there's I do not
believe in the idea of wasted time the
concept of like wasted time waste
experiences I get it I understand where
it comes from but I think there's
something in everything a moment to
learn an observation to be had a thought
that you're like oh I probably wouldn't
have had that thought if I were actively
doing the thing I thought I was going to
be doing but this thought now oh [__]
that's a good idea it's an idea oh [__]
that might change my life you might have
had this honeydew podcast idea while not
even eating honeydew like I should have
been eating melons right now I came to
this melon festival and they're out of
melon this is [__] [__] and
you're like you know what dude I want to
make a version of a melon Festival where
it never runs out and here it is and
here it is here it is but yeah but you
were gonna oh the other thing you wanted
to bring up well I um yeah that's wildly
interesting that it affected you like
that it's it's
and I love what you've done with it too
you got to do something
um let's talk about your other story it
was a an accident involving a girl a
girlfriend yeah so the girl I lost my
virginity to
how old were you 19. okay shocking
shocking I was gonna say I mean for a
guy who you said made no friends or
anything and [__] up at 15. 19 is
earlier earlier than I thought it would
be dude
believe you me when it was happening I
was like oh she doesn't know enough
about me
the answer is just now should have been
31 you know but like
so 19 okay
but um
yeah 19
um
she was [__] cool girl but we uh it
was one of those things where
you know uh I was 19 I was a year out of
high school still a [__] you know no
G no GED yeah uh living with my parents
working for my dad's catering company
just being a [__] [__] she was a
senior in high school she was so she was
18.
um
you know we meet at Mardi Gras which a
lot of you know Mardi Gras [__] Mardi
Gras if you've ever been it's a good
time you know but we went to different
high schools we were both from the same
area and and we start dating and then
it's just one night I don't know if you
remember your first time but mine was
definitely it was terrible yeah mine was
well I remember we couldn't do it it
doggy style was the only position it
worked in for some reason like I just
kept [__] up trying to go missionary
so she's like try it like this and it
worked so I lost my my virginity in the
doggy style position so if you know
anything about me then I think that
explains a lot
about my first yeah that definitely did
not
but yeah the only the only thing that
was interesting and the slightest way
about it was it was we were having a
party at a friend of mine's Place uh
there was Zero Furniture in the house
because his parents had just moved out
of the house entirely and were leaving
it for him right right and so there was
he had no furniture no nothing so it was
just on the floor
in a you know carpet there was carpet
everywhere but on the floor in a bedroom
just no furniture no nothing just
banging on the floor but um but it was
one of those things where
you know that happened you lose your
virginity I you know the Catholic guilt
that I still had because it was I I
don't remember the day exactly or the
date but I know the day was Good Friday
and I do remember it's good Friday 1998
right because I remember being two days
later at like a family Easter party
being like I'm a [__]
I'm a deviant piece of [__] I broke the
Lord's rule even I didn't believe any of
that [__] I still it's still in you but
um
so a week later
uh spring break happened and the spring
break was later uh for high school kids
so it was after Easter for Louisiana for
some reason and we go to Panama City
Florida with a bunch of us right and uh
her and I break up
right like it was during the day we were
just like arguing a lot and she was
complaining that I wasn't spending any
time with her I was just like you know
my friends I'm like yeah we're on spring
[__] break in Panama City the [__]
you have friends like we're all the same
group we're the same group we're us
we're all spending time as a group why
does it [__] matter and she's like I
want to just hang out with just you and
I'm like that's not what spring break's
about what are you talking about and we
just break up we decide right then there
like this isn't working [__] over
[__] you [__] you too so that like is
weird for everyone else because it's
like oh they broke up so like you do in
spring break in Panama City Florida
everybody eventually piles into one car
and gets on the strip and goes three two
and a half one mile an hour even you're
just cruising traffics you're shouting
anyway so there's my friend has a Toyota
Camry there's two people in front
obviously and maybe three then the back
seats falsely pops the trunk right so
myself
uh two friends and then the girl I just
broke up with we were all just kind of
sitting in the trunk like legs hanging
off the bumper yeah right so we're just
whatever she's on one side about on the
other we're not talking our friends are
between us we're like this is weird but
anyway
we're driving along going slow and we
rear end the car in front of us right
but slow it's a slow like tap right and
immediately it's like whoa and then we
hear the car in front of us the dude
drops I was like what the [__] so I'm
like I jump up out of the trunk to go be
like hey hey like I was by this point I
was able to interject you know I was no
longer like I'm not gonna let back I'm
not gonna sit back and let no but I just
go to I go to be like no no it's cool
it's cool so what you know it's all good
the car behind us I remember it was a
Jeep Wrangler
the person driving it is [__]
hammered and had fallen asleep no right
so right into the back
right right in the back of the car three
people's legs dangling right six six
sets of legs all smashed smash it gets
worse the Jeep backs off this girl wakes
up goes oh [__] [__] no puts it in
reverse pops the clutch back and hits
the car behind her right backs into it
so then they're like man on the horn
she's like oh [__] puts it back in first
and oh my God twice
twice all happened in a matter of 10
seconds because we all saw the first
thing happen like Jesus Christ and then
they're all shouting and the car backs
off and it wasn't like the legs looked
crazy because everybody was wearing like
pants but it was still like oh [__] off
and then again and then this time the
guy had to jump in the car and like pull
up because she was just this I don't
know what happened to this person with
her life but I hope she [__] changed
holy [__] because she was like hammered
behind the wheel of a car full of Bumper
to Bumper track bumper bumper traffic
fell asleep while driving a stick shift
by the way which is like that's
difficult that's difficult while driving
a [__] stick so
all three of them legs crap legs [__]
crushed they all [__] fall out of the
I go and I pick up the girl my my girl I
actually pick her up to just get off the
road not realizing oh broken legs when
yeah so then she lets out this [__]
Mega shriek that's just like and it was
[__] insane it was like oh [__] I put
her back on the ground and now there's
suddenly everyone's around you know a
bunch of [__] 19 year old drunk kids
Everyone's an expert on what to do in
that situation right uh then but you
know ambulance eventually comes cops
eventually get their statements are
taken that chick gets arrested
everything's fine the dude driving our
car my buddy Mark he's crying because he
thinks it's all his fault because he
rear-ended no it actually it isn't your
fault you know but it's I think it's
this whole [__] City's fault yeah you
know what I'm saying yeah I think it's I
think it's every it's millions of
people's fault simultaneously but they
go to the hospital as do we and it was a
thing of like okay we're
probably not broken up anymore right
obviously your legs are smashed
right yeah so we like kind of you know I
stay in the hospital got a broken heart
and broken legs
like but eventually one of the dudes
dads was rich so he flies down there
private flies him back to Louisiana
private right he like Charters a [__]
Jet and uh he's a car dealership guys
um so she's back in town I Stay
this is the part people think I'm a dick
for but I stay for like another two days
in Panama just because I was with my
friends were like we're not going back
early [__] you she's fine dude what are
you gonna do go sit she'll be fine I'm
like yeah you're right and I like hang
out for two more days but I still feel
like [__] I get back to Louisiana you
know I'm hanging out at her place every
[__] day but it's like
there's nothing there like we broke up
for a reason you know what I mean like
we're trying to still be like a
boyfriend girlfriend unit but it's like
oh yeah that's there was nothing we lost
our virginity to one another and that
was kind of it because we were both
virgins Right double it was like a
whatever you call that a yeah same way
for me to two like two turtles on their
back yeah yeah yeah make a wish because
it was bad for everyone
yeah yeah but I mean like we both
[__]
we both tried to figure out like this is
a thing right I think it came out of
like you know she was just veggies at
both of her [__] legs broken she had
to have surgery she was in one of the
legs healed way faster so she had she
was on she was in a wheelchair for a
minute oh that was the thing damn she
was in a wheelchair so prom her senior
prom she had to go to prom in a
wheelchair ah [__] right
I went with her right and all of her
friends were dumb [__] [__] about it
they were just what do you mean they
just didn't want to deal with the girl
in the wheelchair really her own friends
yeah they're terrible people wow and
like otta leaned into that horror I mean
but I but it was like my duty that was
the thing well you're her boyfriend I'm
like you're her [__] friend yeah but
like I had to push her everywhere she
wanted to dance
um no one wanted us to ride in their
limo
because she had the [__] voice
we had to like arrange our own ride it
was [__] insane you know what I'm
saying and like we get to the prom
itself and everybody's being weird about
her in a wheelchair it's like you were
all there you saw yeah and then like you
know the prom after party and of course
she wanted to have like prom sex which
was very weird because it's like she was
in like not a cast like a full-on boot
and it was like this thing gets in the
way of any sort of sexiness but we did
you know had drunken
and then like you know we're together
for a few months and it's you know she's
then eventually on crutches but like
there's nothing there like her and I it
was like being in a Loveless marriage at
18 and 19 years old you know where it's
like we have a child we have to stay
together but we didn't have a child we
just had this experience that's right
we're now one of you is she's broken I'm
too much of a [__] [__] to just
be like no we should we should call this
off and so is she we were both
ignorantly like we should try and stay
together and then eventually uh she
cheated on me
right which I knew happened as it was
happening you did and didn't care
because because it was right you're out
that's awesome I knew it happened and
like one of my my buddy he was at the
the party and he's like dude I saw this
and it was weird I just want you to know
and I was like I'm not even upset about
that and then she called me the next day
I'll give her credit for that forever
she called me to be like hey I hooked up
with someone else last night and I said
I know and she got Mega pissed off about
that has she had every right to and then
it was like well now we're just done
right obviously and we eventually like
reconciled and stayed friends but that
experience I mean talk about a [__]
terrible
terrible introduction to love life it's
like love it's like post virginity
like romantic interaction yeah you know
what I mean you're just like well no
you're supposed to stay together even if
you both know you don't want to based on
one event that neither one of you can
control right right yeah I mean like
what if I could go back to that I'd have
just never we'd have just knock out I
still go to the hospital still been like
oh my God I hope you're okay still hung
out until she got flown home but then
never just been like we should stay
together right right like that was just
like you feel so bad for yourself yeah
remove all of your own integrity and
just are like hey I'll just suck this up
and do this right because I got to be
the man here you know and right and you
got to be the you're the older man as
being the opposite 100 yes yeah that's
right you'll learn that immediately like
oh no never do that to yourself again or
to anyone else
but yeah dude that that's one of the
[__] I still think about every time
uh I go to Florida
I think about that moment and then last
year I did shows in Panama City during
the summer and I went and tried to find
I was going to ask you yeah yeah
I don't remember it all I remember is it
happened underneath a walkway it's like
a walkway between two hotels that go
across the road and I found that
Rockwell I was like there it was but
yeah I couldn't tell you the address or
anything like that of the nearest hotel
but like yeah dude that's a [__]
spring break I've never had a good time
on spring break going to maybe three of
those as a kid they were always just a
[__] show I went to one and it was just
it was New Orleans as a matter of fact I
decided time yeah so I was in college I
tell my girlfriend at the time hey I
want to just I've never been to New
Orleans it's Saint Patty's Day lines up
with our spring break up guarantee it's
wild down there it's not Mardi Gras but
it's [__] St Patty's Day it's a St
Patrick's Day parade and we went down oh
man it might as well been Mardi Gras oh
yeah it was floats and parades and I was
getting hit with beads and coins and
everything yeah vegetables I didn't get
hit with vegetables that's a they don't
do it as much but that was a big thing
for years
and what's the big Irish bar there the
Timmy oh well what's it called there's
one called parasols that's the one
that's like the oh but Pat O'Brien
you're talking about that so that place
is going insane that's down
up on Magazine Street that's where the
St Patrick's Day Parade happens on that
parade uh I I don't think they do as
much anymore but they would throw
vegetables because the idea used to be
back in the day you'd collect you'd
collect these vegetables go to your
[__] house make a stew uh and just
anybody on the streets could just have
some [__] stew right
um but there's a there's a bar it's not
I think it's still called parasols I
haven't been in a while but that was
like a legit Irish mafia type [__] oh
yeah okay and that was where like the
pre everybody went to that [__] place
um but
uh St Patrick's Day yeah dude that is a
it's my only spring break
yeah drove my little Honda Civic 1990
Honda Civic with original rims down
stated a shady seedy Motel oh yeah right
outside drove in oh but and then just
[__] walk the French quarter and
partied with the you know yeah masses oh
yeah I mean man is [__] nuts I mean
but spring I went three times to Panama
City right and you remember we're in the
same age group that's where everybody
from our place went to if they went to
Florida it was Panama City and there was
those there was Club La Vela and
Spinnaker both of these both of these
were featured on MTV's spring break were
they okay MTV [__] a lot of people up
yeah and that late 90s era of MTV where
it was like Woodstock three yeah all
this [__] from spring break it made it
made it seem like this amazing [__]
magical time and it wasn't just drunk
[__] doing drunk [__] [__] but
one year at Club Spinnaker we went and
saw two Live Crew no you saw two Live
Crew I saw two Live Crew for about three
and a half [__] maybe honestly 95
seconds into the first song when a
massive fight erupted and they just had
to clear the house in the show oh man it
was [__] insane dude they basically
we get in and it's like oh [__] two Live
Crew and of course two Live Crew doesn't
have like an extensive reel of hits but
everybody knew who they were and they of
course started everybody knows hey we
want some [__] yeah never mind
everybody knows the one and one she
sucked on my band in the USA yeah they
went all the way to the Supreme Court
and won yeah which [__] props times
ten seriously there's actually that
aerial footage you can watch of them
having a full-on orgy on stage during a
concert is there really yeah there's
just like they're just up there [__]
and there's like 18 girls you can look
this you know when it was on dude and I
might I might be conflating but I'm
pretty positive I'm not it was on one of
the Faces of Death episode no [__] I've
seen phases do you remember those two
one of those where for some reason it
was just like oh by the way this here's
this just an aerial shot of an orgy
happening on a two Live Crew concert
where no one dies and now an alligator
eats the sheriff
together but the [__] yeah two Live
Crew starts an hour [__] late
probably I don't remember how late uh
everybody had to go through metal
detector so but but just in the just as
soon as that song starts a fight breaks
out it gets crazy the the members of the
group like whoa whoa lights and the
lights come up and then they have to
clear the [__] room and they
basically kick everyone out and then
they're like they start letting people
back in to do the show but we were like
we're not we're done here we're not
going back yeah [__] that we're gonna go
to Club La Vela where it's worse
um but yeah that's [__] don't go to
spring break I don't even know if kids
do spring I don't know anymore either if
you do spring break now use it as an
actual Adventure like I wish I would
have done that when I was like 20 21
being like Hey we're gonna go to [__]
Europe or we're gonna go to New York
City or we're gonna go to [__]
Chicago and just see places and like oh
we're gonna go hiking or something but
like just going like let's go to Florida
we're all gonna be nine of us in the
hotel room we're gonna [__] drink
Natty light and Natty Ice we're gonna
buy terrible Coke someone's gonna do bad
acid we're gonna have to find them yeah
find them
and they're going to be back where you
they were you originally thought they
were you know someone's gonna get there
while it's still yeah someone's gonna
get their [__] legs crushed yeah yeah
it was just always a bad experience oh
my God but you know yeah like that that
[__] I still think that uh I am I
mean I just got out of an eight-year
relationship for good reasons we're
still friends and [__] but like my
relation the way I dealt with like
relationships going forward from that
event was like I was cautious about
everything over cautious you know about
even telling a woman how I felt yeah
because I was like I don't wanna I don't
I'm too and then I started doing
stand-up a few years later or a couple
years like two years later that changed
everything 22. I was 22 when I started
yeah well that just changed everything
because I mean you remember I think
anybody who does comedy for a long time
knows that like you you discover who you
really are in that first year because
you're up there because of your ideas
because of what you're saying on stage
you start to realize like man I didn't
even know that about me until I had to
present it to strangers [__] I could
never tell family could barely tell
friends there's little things too like I
didn't realize how much I said [__] or
whatever until I started listening back
to myself I'm like oh my God I dropped
that like 20 times in a five minute set
what the hell I don't need to do it that
much I didn't realize how obsessed with
ass I was yeah yeah or how much I liked
making bird sounds you're like you start
listening back to yourself like why do I
do that voice and that's where Gilbert
Godfrey came from even I think that's
how he naturally talked but rip one of
the best R.I.P Gilbert Godfrey yeah man
that's uh you find the beauty and all
that [__] all right so now after
everything we've talked about this is
your first time here I'm gonna ask you
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self advice I would give to my 16
year old self is don't think about being
cool
don't try try actively to not follow the
herd because you end up doing that great
advice you end up doing that anyway
don't compare yourself to others don't
accept the fact that you're a any 16
year old you're a dorky develop you're
in development You're Not a Human Being
yet you're learning about who you are
you're still growing you're still
changing so much your life is ahead of
you you should not be at all concerned
with who you are at that age know who
you are and lean into it but know that
it's Gonna Change you're gonna grow
you're gonna get [__] wiser smarter
better looking
more Adept at whatever you want to do in
life so just do that the accept that
you're flawed at 16 more than any other
year in your life and the rest of your
life will be great I believe that that's
great dude yeah well listen man this has
been a really fun great episode thank
you I appreciate you coming on here yeah
um please plug and promote everything
again make sure you hit that YouTube
channel yes make sure you subscribe so
yeah me seanpatton.com uh Sean Patton
comedian on YouTube
uh Mr Sean Patton on Instagram and you
know follow me on that I post a lot I
posted on that all the time I know it's
three different things but there's
[__] an obnoxious amount of Sean
patterns that don't do comedy that have
all this that have all the Sean Patton
yeah [__] [__] locked down so I have
the added fine little tricks but yeah
and the peacock special it's called
number one that is not arrogant it is
based on
life is a bedwetter number one and it's
also my first special so it's like but
it's I love that one too so check them
all out I'm here doing it all right
doing it big Ryan sickler thank you for
coming on yeah I'm just gonna say it
like I always say as always
ryansickler.com Ryan sickler on all
social media we'll talk to you all next
week
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]